hi I'm Ryan Sumner and I'm a chief
network architect with IBM cloud do you
know what BPC means and why it even
matters to you and your public cloud
journey well today I'm going to break it
down be PC or virtual private cloud is a
public cloud capability that provides
you the ability to define and then
control isolated virtual networks and
then deploy cloud resources into those
networks so what's a virtual network
well to help you understand that let me
first help you understand how we would
deploy networks in a standard public
cloud an administrator is going to
define a backbone
I thought backbone is gonna carry all
the traffic in that cloud there's going
to be some segmentation on that backbone
to create a separation between one
client and another client or let's even
say separation between one application
and another application within the same
client so now that we have that
segmentation we need a network function
to actually allow us to have
communication between those segments I
know we're function we're going to call
a router so now that we have
communication between these segments I
might choose to say I don't want traffic
to flow between this segment in that
segment let's say because this is
customer a and this is customer B so now
I have a firewall function that provides
us with filtering capability so now I
have my cloud defined it's completely
isolated it's not connected to the rest
of the world but I need Internet
connectivity because I'm hosting a web
application here so now I need a network
function that's gonna provide me with
nattie in addition I need to extend my
enterprise or I have applications here
that need to communicate and get data
from my enterprise on-site so I'm going
to build a VPN function so in a
traditional cloud environment almost all
these network functions are actually
done with appliances they're done with
appliances that required infrastructure
administrators or network
administrator's to login to them using a
proprietary interface to define all
these flows and controls
if you look at virtual networking
however we introduce all of these
capabilities as a service let me trace
all these capabilities to the user to
where they can now create these
functions and create this isolation and
this segmentation with a UI or a CLI or
an API so they might be able to say I
want four of these networks and I want
to define my own custom segmentation for
this application or that application now
I want to have connectivity to my
enterprise I provision a VPN service to
get connectivity to the Internet instead
of having a configuring adding I provide
I provision a service to be able to give
me that that ability so now the user has
this control and they didn't need to
know any proprietary interfaces to make
these to make these connections or
define these flows and since each of
these are networks they're completely
isolated with each other they don't have
connectivity between each network until
I say so
so now let's talk about a few of the
benefits right now you understand where
the virtual network comes into play and
how that actually contributes to the
private piece of the PC so some of the
benefits are because now I can get all
these all these functions and I have
isolation built in I have some security
aspects in addition since these aren't
appliances and it's actually provided as
a capability of the cloud I can do all
of this at scale again developers need
things that are customizable right so so
the aspect of being able to define the
segmentation and say I want four or five
or six or tear it all down and come back
tomorrow and do it again I need some
aspects of custom customizing this
environment in addition it's flexible
enough
now the user to be able to say I need to
be able to add virtual segmentation
later on down the road or I need
connectivity to the enterprise down the
road so all of these these two
attributes here actually allow the
developers to become more agile which
hopefully is going to save you some
money so now you understand virtual
private cloud and why it matters to you
we hope you like this video on V PC if
you did or you have any questions please
comment below and don't forget to Like
and subscribe